yeah this is moines this is uh a place
where they bring you when you've just
come from the border the board is just
up there crossing called krakowitz uh we
were there and we came down on a bus
with uh a number of dozens and dozens of
people who had just arrived from ukraine
uh into poland and and this is
where they are brought if we just walk
around i can show you this collection
here you will see
of people holding signs this is what
greets you when you get off the bus
are all of these signs now what they're
offering is accommodation
they're offering transport they're
offering journeys to
neighboring uh neighbouring towns
sometimes actually some of the big
cities as soon as i'm
offering to take people the crack of
that a fair two and a half hour journey
even jehovah's witnesses uh over there
offering uh offering support
and we traveled here i have to say with
people who ranged
in emotions from either
jubilant pleased to get out of their
country
or absolutely exhausted crestfallen
devastated
i was standing on on the bus looking at
this young woman who must have been in
her early 20s i'm not sure i've ever
seen
somebody look quite so distraught quite
so
hollowed uh
and tired
but if we show you here just as another
bus
arriving here will move on and they will
be greeted i think by all of this this
wave uh of good will
and attention now a lot of these people
who come off will actually have
uh families or support uh with them
people who have come
uh to greet them
and these are not just ukrainians when i
was here a few moments ago was chatting
to a group of african there was some
from angola from nigeria from tanzania
they were studying they'd been in in
kiev one in kharkiv uh a couple in
odessa
and had found themselves suddenly caught
up in this war and looking for
a way out and had been met by embassy
staff here who will take them
away now the overwhelming sense you have
is that poland is doing everything it
can
to make people welcome that the normal
rules
around
uh border crossings have been taken away
look at this lady coming through here
let's give her some space with her child
um
seeing a lot of children uh
and and
should remind ourselves that almost all
of these people
with all of the ukrainians who are
coming out here
are women and children men between 18
and 60
have been told
to stay in ukraine and to fight for
their country and that is what you see
is the vast majority of visitors uh our
of arrivals should say are
women and children these buses come
regularly this isn't a kind of once of
an hour thing
and they are running 24 hours a day and
one of the reasons for that is that on
the other side it's a couple of miles
from us
on the ukraine side of the border the
the queues are vast
we have car cues that now go back
25 miles maybe 30 miles
and the predictions of how long you will
be in that queue keep going up it was a
day
yesterday we reported it as having gone
from two days maybe two and a half days
i'm told today
it's three days
and those cues are simply getting longer
it's in film also of
people trying to get on the train in la
viv uh in ukraine to come here
to poland which is the first stop inside
the eu and again those platforms are
absolutely
packed another bus uh arriving here and
i can see a very very small child
sitting
right at the front
of that bus and it is this continuous
wave of humanity
that i think
strikes you is completely shocking and
we have to pinch ourselves
and remind ourselves this is europe i'm
in the european union right now this
isn't some
distant conflict that is that is more
difficult to understand this is the
european union there is war raging
miles away over there in ukraine
the biggest country in europe other than
russia
and the european union is having to pick
up the pieces
and yesterday
uh the eu made a couple of important
decisions one germany allowing weapons
to be brought
in to blue supply to ukraine we've seen
military vehicles a large military
convoy heading to the the border
so far and also these decisions
about uh curtailing russia's access to
finance those are all the political
decisions
but this
is the real world effect